[Music]
how has the pregnancy been you've been
feeling good you look beautiful are you
ready no I'm not ready at all
I'm in a lot of pain this time the first
time I was pregnant I was pregnant with
like a bunch of my girlfriends like
Lacey Chabert Ashley Jones and Davidson
who are all here tonight we all had our
first ones at the same time so yeah it
kind of all went through together
and I'm all I tried to convince them all
to get pregnant with me this time Kaylee
- oh really can we all just get pregnant
at the same time not chasing around a
toddler now yeah so it's different this
time
I mean I'm good I'm having like the
doctor said the doctor legit told me to
stop eating so much I'm only been
getting you the doctor was like how much
weight have you gained I was like um 25
pounds and I was 27 weeks it's like a
week ago and she's like fight as much as
you've been eating before Ali Fedotowsky
was married with kids she was the
Bachelorette when et spoke with her at
the Paul works ties and Tails gala over
the weekend we had to ask her thoughts
on our elion Dyke juniors recent
bachelor bombshell because I'd been in
aa race position I know what like I'm a
brain fog arid and the only thing he did
really wrong in my opinion
is that he wasn't completely honest with
Lauren about his relationship with Becca
and he had cameras come for the breakup
I think that he handled it the wrong way
he should have he should not he
shouldn't have said I love you as much
as he did he misled both girls way too
much so don't give him a pass for that
that was wrong but I do for the whole
proposing to to people
you
[Music]